but what the [ __ ] are you doing that
poll just wondering what are you wearing
I'm in there uh no it's just me
sorry
what
but do you know where are you going now
Oh
like I just kept the game going before I
was gonna record all right that'll be a
good intro right welcome back to gentle
faces maybe we should wait for the best
game ever made ever
we're taking sinister down ourselves
this is our game
ah [ __ ] aw [ __ ] half a shield doesn't
matter
hahahaha [ __ ] I'm fun okay let's get
got this will be the last episode of
then pool which makes me a little sad I
think so good you're fine
look oh yeah a maze what player don't I
may get it come on drop okay I have a
guy what is this place going on stop
running away from me oh hey are you done
good but the fastest boss battle ever
stop stop shooting there I'll shoot you
I'll shoot you either way actually
you're too damn or not oh [ __ ] Wow baby
baby man why can't we just be here oh
snap oh crap no not the cannon balls
okay the chubby he loves him
that's why chubby stop stopping chump
now wait that's racist
that's to Toby
you gotta spray them in the [ __ ] head
there we go go away no one likes you the
clothes no anything but the clones
oh [ __ ] these are actually pretty bad
you can't be killed
make our head Oh
what is more more again it's an orgy of
destruction chaos Wow
third is my other gun no wonder the
Cointreau
Oh [ __ ] easy
come at me bro oh that's oh my god here
come for I love the lion guys come on
man
be careful yes mam animals of the soup
they're [ __ ] it
I think we kill them yeah [ __ ] that was
so many [ __ ] ridiculous what is he
gonna do now oh god of course more good
good
oh no not all of them
ah come on ah dad one yeah god damn it
look at this [ __ ] what no it's not I'm
getting [ __ ] Oh everybody's the new
blockbuster smells better oh we need to
hold your hand Richford she died to
defend
[ __ ] it's marking fam
okay she's dead
there we go and he's [ __ ] then there
we go and that's how you kill them now
what the [ __ ] do you want how do we come
back here oh that was [ __ ] easy just
one shot what thanks thanks oh it's
anything not so many of them mode
oh no that's like three m4 they could
have sex with each other
Oh what tough come on what do you want I
don't even know your super abilities
okay we got two other voids
it's [ __ ] difficult boss honestly I
just keep coming but I think I have a
good
oh [ __ ] they have a shield Maps horse
[ __ ] hell
again
yes baby success Texas drop me and you
do the kind of stuff not only printed
thing about what you aim them um yes yes
yes
[ __ ] yeah high five Wow and now you come
oh oh she made it [ __ ] you want to
report it
reporting beautiful handsome charming
you're getting it wrong man
well here we are the moment I know why I
didn't believe it you know I wasn't sure
how you do but gotta say have a dinner
breath me Christian Christ we make an
amazing team dearly that's I breath
tears we should do this more often
yeah I got officiator for the game if we
did it this way you know okay
whatever whatever just have a button to
execute our super awesome amazing plan
sinister is standing right um shut up
stupid don't spoil it
whatever you're ready we're never ever
are you ready for us are you ready to
ten please stop scratching your ass
friends be for polygons you want to go
make a sandwich while the master villain
stands behind me ready to strike I don't
right ahead okay thanks
thanks I know it could be hard your exit
logs
beside button presses like this one but
you we believe in you
these moments are my favorite in the
game on here FYI okay again get to know
I like I even send us sirs ready
together don't give up now I'm not
giving up I'm just I just like to see
you scratch your ads it's not it's not
totally reminds me of that one time with
those other dudes when we totally did
that one thing and everyone busted up
laughing that's funny fell over
and we were all like boys at their
button okay okay okay sorry hi
I can't think that's it okay
let's cook it ha ha ha ha I hope so yeah
best game ever
I keep saying that about every game but
seriously best character ever at least
Danny buddy
well I call it met it the game rock you
rock
ow thanks pal pal I hate to admit this
but we're actually not that much over
budget and want to tell you that before
but now the game oh I know what's good
athletic uh yeah get your checkbook
ready
why oh that is not gonna custom anything
all right so that was that pool too cool
for school in the brook pool pool okay
hope you bros enjoyed this game I had a
lot of fun yeah I don't let you can't be
that's what they told me maybe all I can
teach just a little bit of a bit of the
rest right up Weapon X well we'll see
you next Oh
expect a miracle bent on the devil lab
your best friend if you keep my money
level never without a gun I don't wanna
fish it out
it's about
okay it's not that great wrapping Nolan
or the stem in the Carib crimp it means
domicile watch what that means great
yeah great
where we live ah I knew that who's
hungry uh me actually are you bros
hungry oh wow it's getting funky yeah
what the [ __ ]
hardly anyway I can't talk again oh wow
of course it has to finish her that
[ __ ] love that ending honestly you
knew it was gonna end in a funny an epic
way but yeah that was a lot of fun I
hope you bros had fun as well I'm gonna
miss this game because I don't honestly
there's like few games that really hits
that the comedy in a good good spot I
mean I think Conker's Bad Fur Day and
bully are the only two games that I
really play that I thought was like
legitimately funny I don't think a lot
of games try to be funny too
it's kind of weird isn't it but I do
hope a lot of people hope for a sequel
first of all honestly like I I didn't
want to start playing this game because
I didn't know who the [ __ ] Deadpool was
and I knew nothing about the game and
usually most most of the the games that
are based on comic book heroes have not
been good in my opinion maybe the
fighting games but not the one that it's
based on just one character so I didn't
think Deadpool is gonna be good at all
but maybe that's why I enjoyed it even
more you know i was so i don't know i
really like loved it right away and you
know you totally don't have to be a fan
of deadpool and going into this but
going out of it you'll you will be a fan
of that pool so that was cool I really
really like that I kind of miss his
series a lot but I want to thank you
bros for watching it with me it really
means a lot you bros are awesome when
you make you make this possible for me
to do so
really appreciate it yeah again thanks
for watching bro
stay awesome love you